the Royal Yacht Britannia is shipped one
of the world's most famous families
across the seas for 40 years it offers a
personal history like few other
attractions it carried the British royal
family for state visits and holidays
Charles and Diana's honeymoon and was
even used in a refugee rescue in the
Yemen retired in Scotland's capital
Edinburgh the Britannia was
recommissioned as a top visitor
destination now with an audio tour
available in 27 different languages its
potential is being maximized the vested
economy is worth 11 billion pounds to
Scotland employs over 300,000 people I'm
switch hugely important those arguing
for Scotland to remain in the UK say
attractions like the Britannia are at
risk from independence the UK was the
eighth largest tourist destination in
the world in 2013 so will Scotland
jeopardize those extending holidays from
places like London with its open borders
and a shared currency those voting yes
counter by saying Scotland will be even
more visible on the international stage
and could in fact attract more
international flights by cutting
passenger duty and reducing taxes on
tourists whatever the result the real
damage could be done by Scotland's
biggest group of visitors eighty-two
percent of the visitors to Scotland are
from the united kingdom however the
international visitor is very important
because they spend double the amount
that a UK Vista does if people from the
UK feel antagonized by Scotland
separation the tourism industry north of
the border will have to work to keep
their big-spending visitors from
elsewhere staying longer Tom Gibson
Bloomberg